America's crime crisis taking a bite out
of California's most well-known fast
food chain in and- Out Burger will be
closing its only Oakland location which
has been open for nearly two decades the
company citing crime and safety concerns
is the reason why an opinion columnist
for the San Francisco Chronicle isn't
pleased by the move she tweeted quote
remember In-N-Out as in some benevolent
institution it's a fast food chain
driven by profit goals if in-n-out's
primary concern is the well-being of the
communities it serves it wouldn't be
leaving
judge why me first I'm disgusted by this
you know so you shouldn't worry about
the number of employees that are
assaulted and when they leave the new
employees coming in who don't want to
take the job potential employees because
they don't want to get assaulted or you
know the fact that it takes police
longer to get there because the police
have been defunded or 911 isn't as fast
as it used to be and you know you can't
get employees who want to work late
because everybody's getting beat up or
the cars are broken into outside and you
hope your insurance company will still
Co cover you and this woman who was a
former blogger who was a co-host of a
podcast called the racist sandwich she
wants she wants you to stay in business
because she does I mean it's just stupid
well that's why I went to you first uh
Charlie this in andout has been there
for 20 years it's actually part of the
community and people's kids have worked
there and then gone on to college and
I'm just impressed by the amount of
homework you did for this block she like
got everything RAC sandwich I'm glad you
I missed that part but you but then
again you also sort of mopped up all the
important points um no uh but no but
this is this is like the definition of
the actual definition of communism where
you control the means of production and
you say no you cannot go out of business
e even though you're the same people not
you but but these people these people
out there they're the same people who
have ushered in all of the misery with
all of their crazy lunatic policies that
make it uh have to close in the first
place Greg do you like In-N-Out burger
or what a burger trying to think of what
a racist sandwich could be like that's
what I want to
knowm a blmt well she talks about race
gender in class in sandwiches she has a
lot of time in her hands she does not go
outside she's in a footsies footsie
pajamas holding a cat that's what her
life is that's why she says you should
keep it open because she doesn't outside
when you hear that another store is
closing in Oakland you're always shocked
that there's still remaining stores in
Oakland that's if you're going to open a
store in Oakland that's like getting
dressed for the Captain's Table at the
Titanic it's common knowledge though
this is Gavin nome's favorite family
restaurant so this is a direct attack on
laundry no no no for his family for his
family because and also he would use the
grease from the burger wrappers to
shellack his hair so this is a big gut
punch to Nome more so than the burgers
eles this has got to
hurt Martha well I think everything's
been said but um you know I would just
say that it it's a it's a it's the
town's responsibility to encourage small
business to thrive right and you do that
by giving them incentives to stay open
maybe they should be giving companies
tax breaks in order to encourage them to
be in Oakland and then they're going to
have to provide police security and you
know when people break in they're going
to have to put them in jail it's pretty
simple equation okay hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else